on it need i say more
you want focus you want good sleep
you want good mood you want good
digestive health dude i'm watching
support
always telling people to get on it if we
have to convince you to
buy on it i'm a punch in yourself
especially now though they got stuff for
your immune system shroom tech immune
literally proven to work right now if i
do anything without alpha brain no i'm
not basing it out
you are you are a guy who takes you've
been taking on as long as i've known you
forever and and uh you know for me i've
always used their product i've used
their that i'm i'm telling you their
total gut health cured
my [ __ ] nausea i had after i had food
poisoning for a month
no i didn't have that yeah you did [ __ ]
off okay but that [ __ ] really works
they're total hemp they're they're
they're incredible acrylic
i swear by their nutrients they got
freaking total gut health like brian
said
new mood alpha brain alpha brain instant
put in your water bottle
you need fitness all right what do you
need steel club steel maces
quad maze kettlebells sandbags you're
gonna work out at home
on demand training on it six barbell
body weight kettlebell steel mace
durability they got streaming fitness
for your thick ass all right
go to onyt.com
for 10 off the whole goddamn website
[ __ ] yeah coffee
black rifle on it got together toss some
caffeine
uh crystals in there you're going to be
jacked to the gills on caffeine [ __ ]
that coffee black rifle
on it best coffee ever on it.com slash
fighter
10 percent off there it is it's wanker
wednesday hike or wednesday buddy
what are you doing dude well i'm not
obviously not
ironing your shirt no no i i couldn't i
spent uh all morning crying
i did that i spent all morning crying
why because your eyes didn't go
no no because uh because i watched the
end of outcry
oh you bought you finally five episodes
it it it
it'll get to you yank in your heart and
and the most embarrassing thing am i
right about it
you're right about it my girl's on me
and i'm crying like this and she goes
oh my sensitive boy you want a kleenex i
go i'm not crying
and she goes brian i can feel your
[ __ ] tears
landing on my shoulder you're crying a
girl's shoulder that's how hard i was
crying right because
because when he got off when he got off
i was like oh when you when he was
telling me he was like you know he's
just someone believes
that [ __ ] had how down was his
six years she's a badass
his girl her family they're amazing
great [ __ ] amazing people in his
family
oh but isn't it crazy like when you're
first watching it when they the
four-year-old does his interview not the
second second was completely full of
[ __ ] but the first one you're like
that's [ __ ] might have done it
because you kind of go down this weird
road
children children people that that do
this
children when you ask them a question
and you come back and ask the same
question
they have trouble um four-year-olds have
trouble between reality
and perceived perception or or what you
put in their brain
so they've stud they've done those
studies they showed it on the they
showed it up they showed it where
children
will make up what happened to them even
though they have it on video but
off the interviewer too like if the
interview is going now did they touch
your vagina
and they go no right you sure he didn't
you come back a week later and they said
yes
so so i haven't had a sip of whiskey and
i don't know how long have you have a
little sip and i might have one
and i'm gonna do it for our boy who on
outcry his name
his name is uh uh greg greg
kelly kelly because i forgot what a
looker what a looker
good looking dude you know what six
years later started lose his hair father
time
maybe barbara maybe a little bit but he
was growing it up where you what you saw
the man
by the second episode i saw the [ __ ]
other kid in there and i went they look
so much alike
did nobody put this together well that's
what they're saying is the
the audacity of the prosecution team
that doesn't or the how about how about
how about the law enforcement there
didn't he even interview anybody in the
house didn't ask the kids to pick out of
a lineup they just said greg and they
i think they look similar i think what
happens is you're a detective bad people
though
well or you're or you're a detective and
you go
this these children were molested and
you say
and you you hear the child say the guy's
name so what happens is
in your mind through your experience
your emotion
you might say i have to get this guy
convicted but that's not the way it
works i know it's not even how does that
happen
but human beings are getting i can't
have that no you're not getting off that
there's no way that gets off that easy
because you have another gentleman
living in the house oh it's crazy
and you don't crazy he looks like him
you don't interview him and then you
don't even do a
uh a visual terrible going to hate is
this greg sister greg kelly yeah and i
bet the kid was like uh maybe
you show them other guys this greg kelly
kid right right yeah he made up his mind
which is insane he made up his mind
which is insane and and his lawyer was
you know i mean oh they were all in on
it wow the lawyer you know what the
justice system worked
six years later the justice didn't work
because
he was he lost three years of his life
in prison and then you're
coming out three years fighting it so
six years total crazy
when he when he's how frustrating is it
uh we just gave away the series sorry
guys but
you know um it was very cathartic well
if i
if i tell you about uh a documentary or
a show and you don't watch it
by the a day or two we're gonna we have
to talk that's what we do
we gotta talk about gotta talk about it
isn't it amazing i'm trying to get him
on fire the kid
i'd love to get him on he worked at an
honor in in uh austin yeah he wants to
walk on and he's probably over texas
uh austin now he looks like he's a very
strong kid and very happy we had a full
ride to university of texas san antonio
had a full ride to rice
so he must play something else but what
is done
what's your take on that after all he
hasn't played in six years
hard and played football in six years
very hard very hard but there's some
there's something
to be said because you know my my
quarterback in college
um joel klatt he was 26 27 years old
because he went from playing high school
football
then he played professional baseball he
was like double a
[ __ ] athlete yeah so he played
baseball but so he didn't play for a
number of years and when you're older
more mature it's such an advantage oh
yeah like even you know how it is like
well your son's not into sports but if
he was like if it from
from third grade to fifth grade huge oh
huge so if you can you know if you want
your son to play sports if he can hold
him back
so he's a lot of characters especially
these days they do that with hockey
yeah yeah sandbagging but just like you
know
sandbagging but for joel clatt he was
you know 27
we were trying to you know hook up with
girls and party after games while he was
studying
he was 27 years old oh that's 26 or 27
that's
chris winky who won the heisman same
thing look at that
handsome devil look at that tiny mask
mike catherine would looking like the
picture of [ __ ] looking good brother
looking out of it thanks for answering
the bell and lady
ryan there's never a bad time to save
money buddy especially on home insurance
dude
ever shopping ever yup shopping your
home insurance rates
with policy genius could save you a good
chunk of change
and the best part is you barely need to
lift a finger to do it here's how it
goes you first head to policygenius.com
answer a few quick questions about
yourself and your property
then policy genius will compare your
policy against options
from top insurers to make sure you're
getting the right home insurance
coverage at the best possible price
and if policy genius finds you a better
rate than what you're currently paying
they'll do all the work you own a car
too dude yeah
policy genius will compare your home and
auto policies across different insurers
and even mix and match to find you
savings they've saved their customers
the average of a thousand
dollars and a hundred thousand hundred
twenty seven wow i thought just a
thousand
nope so if you'd like to put a little
cash back in your pocket right now
see how much you can save by reshopping
your home insurance rates at
policygenius.com now you want to smell
good but i don't want like aluminum i
don't want all the toxins you know
and you want to smell like a bunch of
like you know perfume okay i don't smell
homeless either
my native deodorant it doesn't just
block odor better it's
made better it has ingredients you've
heard of like coconut oil
shea butter tapioca starch it's vegan
never tested on animals oh thank god i
hate when they potassium well aluminum
forms a plug in your sweat glands to
keep you from sweating that's what i'm
saying dude yep that's why
native never uses ingredients like
aluminum parabens sulfates and aluminum
free deodorant doesn't mean you have to
sacrifice on
odor protection native will keep you
smelly and feeling fresh
all day long over 10 cents jeez
oh yeah got lavender rose cucumber mint
citrus and herbal my favorite's the mint
i gotta be honest
i love the mint native is risk free to
try even products come with free
shipping within the us of a
plus free 30-day returns and exchanges
see why so many people love native and
check out the over fourteen
000 five-star reviews do what we did
and make the switch to native today by
going to native d-o
that's d-e-o native d-e-o dot com slash
t-fat k
or use the promo code t-fat k at
checkout get 20
off your first order that's native
deo.com
t-fat k or use promo code t-fat cat
check out for 20
off your first order good to have you
back man oh dude
it's great to be here i mean look at
looking shaped just
thick and mexican shiny and beautiful i
did
yeah congratulations who cut your hair
um
the uh standards and supply standard and
supply i think
in venice california okay it's a uh
california hippie barber shop you know
kind of like
it's a barber shop but it's like yeah a
fashiony barbershop you know we're
talking about outcry
did you see it the documentary on
showtime oh dude it's unbelievable
is that the one where the guy got
falsely accused of uh yeah
like when they when they first told me
about i'm like alright i'll check it out
then i had nothing to do yeah and i
watched them like holy [ __ ]
i have a weird thing where i love
anything
fiction has to be horrible and dark
and terrible and about murder and just
the disgust and the depravity of human
kind but
anything uh non-fiction
i i i get really bummed out like it
really affects me if i
don't scare you and bums you see all i
can watch and read is non-fiction i will
not watch anything or re
i would definitely not read a book on
fiction all i do is read fiction now
i read novels now because i went through
so many years of not i agree
so much value yeah i find a lot of value
in fiction because it makes you more
creative it makes me
not me i love all non-fiction learn from
the past i'm gonna i'm gonna make you a
little list of uh
some really good books i don't have time
you'll get lost seven books on pueblo
escobar no
i love it but i do i can't get enough of
it you'll get lost in some books because
they're just as true as non-fiction
no if it didn't happen my brain goes no
no it did happen though in a way so so
sometimes like
what's funny about metaphor and story is
that it's just as true
i know this sounds weird but i'm making
already non-fiction which actually
happened there's but you gotta remember
i
don't have the history background of me
so for me yeah yeah
i love your tom and nixon and jfk all
that stuff i missed no but what
is getting at it is very true in that um
like like
like don quixote for example it's
completely made up
but as you're reading it you're like
this has happened yeah
70 000 times about a man
who is essentially a walking anachronism
a man who is
still trying to live the old way in a
modern world right yeah and so it's very
but i i totally hear you because right
now for you
what i think is very interesting about
your transition which which i really
appreciate and also speaks to your
intelligence
is that you didn't grow up you grew up
majoring in sports
and what happened was as you're older
the world has started to affect you
covid um all this stuff uh all these
social changes and what's happening is
you are starting to see that
politics and the philosophy they're in
and all that is really affecting your
life in some ways a negative way and you
don't have
recourse so what you're doing which is
what what i've said before
is that when you feel like you don't
have ammunition you need ammunition and
knowledge examination educate yourself
educate yourself you're reading you're
reading history you're reading where the
stuff comes from
so now you have an interest in it isn't
it funny it start from you though we're
hanging out with i hope so i appreciate
it but then also
like we think right now is like such a
terrible time and
it's you know everything's so polarized
and trump's the worst like we've gone
through this how about nixon
how about nixon my father said that my
father's 80 and my father jfk
my dad said none of this is new he goes
one of the things when you're 80 is you
realize
that this is your regular this is the
american story
black lives matter george floyd uh
protests
uh covid a little bit different but but
this is the american story
all of this stuff all these changes and
at every single generation
there's nothing negative about it it's
just reality it's kind of the human
existence
i think the human experience especially
for americans is that we all think our
time
is the great disaster it's our times the
like this is we're really [ __ ] now i
mean feels like
every one of our parents and every one
of our grandparents and every one of our
great grandparents you know however far
back you go
in this country all of them said well
the country i knew is gone to pot we're
[ __ ] that's this is it everybody this
is it we're
what about what are our kids getting
what world are our kids going to grow up
in
older generation always says that about
the younger generation oh everybody the
younger generation doesn't know where
hard work and
yeah they do you know what's funny i
made my girl watch philadelphia the
other it was on
and it just started out you haven't seen
philadelph she wasn't like we have
denzel watching tom hanks
are you the aides pandemic i didn't know
i was in that oh he's the lawyer he's
fantastic
he's so he's so good in it i go you are
you
you're worried about clovid do you know
aids in the
80s that's me i know i started using
some of your clothes and she goes
we're the same age what the [ __ ] do you
know about aids yeah i was like from
philadelphia from brian like it was a
real problem i i live with that
i lived that in new york and i saw with
my own eyes i watched men
waste away and it was some of the worst
stuff i've ever seen
dude if next time you guys have drew on
you gotta like
carve out time specifically to talk
about that because
i think i think new york city and
obviously san francisco
had just a completely different level of
it
but in in la drew dr drew pinsky was at
the very forefront along with dr falci
by the way yeah um
with the what they called at the time
grids um
gay related immune disorder i believe
um and which turned out to be hiv aids
it was so disgusting
so beyond what you can even imagine the
way people died i mean
that's the thing so many were dying but
not so many were dying like
falling over your face you're watching
someone
a human go from perfectly healthy
beautiful person to
just deteriorate and like like it looked
like a zombie mine
how many people died from aids in the in
the night let's say
when was like the hotbed so so late so
many gay men
the entire gay community the entire
artistic community the theater world in
new york the dance community in new york
was so devastated i'm telling you
everybody died but sex really
oh there was it was everybody who was a
fashion the fashion world the dance
world the theater world
was absolutely decimated um
i mean like beyond what you can imagine
but my next door neighbor my neighbor
eric wonderful guy um he it started to
affect his brain
and he came out and i never forgot he
had tubes in his nose
and he said do you want a dog do you
want a dog i'll give you my dog do you
want a dog she's making me nuts
i mean i love her but and he was going
crazy yeah me and my girlfriend were
like oh
it's there you go now a lot of people
are living with it though like i
remember
magic johnson when he got it my brother
started crying yeah he loved magic
johnson
but he was fine in it well now they have
medications protease inhibitors
when you're hiv positive you can't just
it's actually a problem too i mean
obviously it's not a problem because
people are living
but it is a problem too a lot of my
older gay friends they're like
these party and play kids now they know
aids is in the death sentence and it's
almost like
a feather in their cap they're like
[ __ ] raw dog every day let's
do it doesn't matter like aids [ __ ] it
not only that you know what the aids has
had to compromise itself so often
as a virus that you can now get it and
they think you can stay off medication
oh wow it kind of incubates forever
because it's a greek
yeah but dude i remember it so well i
got many aids tests because before we
thought it was a
straight disease yeah at the height you
know it was almost 41 000 and 90
[ __ ] the height was 41 000 died in 96
the difference was brennan is that when
you got aids it was a death sentence
and you've got to remember that 41 000
was out of excuse me it was out of a
very small
most of it 99 of it was in a small
community
so it seemed like every gay person just
every
gay person you knew was
was because it was primarily a gay
disease and an intravenous drug using
disease
the media considered that prejudicial oh
for sure so there was a lot of pressure
on
cbs and abc and these different
companies and there's a book about it
called
i think it's called the news about the
news camera i read it but
uh and and there was a lot of i'm sorry
if that's not the book but there's a lot
of pressure on these
on the networks to find straight people
who had aids
so what happened was they would do these
stories on a straight gal from orange
county
with blonde hair who had it or they or
some guy but the truth was
the truth was it was almost specifically
a gay disease
and the men who were taking it not men
who were who were giving it
men were not tops but bottoms the
bottoms because they were getting it
they were getting pushed into their
i'll tell you firsthand the anal tissue
very soft it's uh
the reason it was a heterosexual disease
in africa and they couldn't figure out
why
was because africa sub-saharan africa
didn't suffer from the plague
from the bubonic plague and if you
suffer from if you if you all of us who
have who are of european
uh descent have a
have a variant in our gene that makes us
resistant to the bubonic plague to it to
an extent
which also makes you resistant to aids
interesting and that's why it was a
[ __ ] hell they couldn't figure out
why
in certain parts of southeast asia and
especially in africa
it was a heterosexual disease where men
and women were
getting it all the time but it was slim
to vanishing in this
heterosexual uh european population i
saw
i saw some lady on the news she she was
like 109.
she had the plague she had the spanish
flu and she got coveted
and survived all of it whoo that we need
to hang out
right right but she survived extract her
dna
and just provide it to everyone so that
she could my grandma got my grandma's 94
she got it in an old folks home where
five people five other old folks have
died and she just co-veterates
covet yeah so they say you never and she
did 94 she got it uh
she tested negative and we're like oh
[ __ ] because like i said
all the five other senior assistants in
her
in her home had passed so i was like man
we gotta start
preparing for yeah you don't want to get
80 percent of the time she passed
she she totally went right through her
and she's fine and it never even like
negatively affected you you
no i would love to have doctor draw now
that how much we know and the stats we
know about cobit now
i'd love to get him back in he'd love to
be here but yeah
but but i don't understand why the
science isn't diffusing into the brains
of mothers who are still saying i want
to keep my kids out of school
i i i look we had it yeah and
i i stay i stick by what i said which is
i'm still against the shutdown the
blanket shutdown have you had it mike
no that's my point of view and that's my
opinion
and one can argue with when people see
it follow the science yeah
i can follow the science and so i just i
don't get it
in my opinion the big problem is is that
you just said something
that a lot of people may disagree with
but was very measured and very
i think logical you're not saying uh
it's against my [ __ ] rights i'm not
wearing a mask [ __ ] you no no you're
just saying like look there is
a lot of science showing that it is
overwhelmingly
only affecting a very limited group of
the population the the the old and the
uh people who have pre pre-existing
where it's deadly right yeah and um and
even that's all
that's fallen is the most reasonable
thing to do
because of knowing acknowledging that
it's only affecting this amount of
people
is is the most reasonable thing to do to
shut down the entire economy to to
prevent kids from going to school and
socializing
um there could be a lot more negative
side effects in comparison to just the
virus
in and of itself by just saying that
there's this weird
people have this this emotion strange
kind of almost like
it's you're you're you're committing
this dog whistle where you're saying
f science evidence like no no wait i'm
i'm i'm gonna
figure this out by the way what i don't
understand is
why not report the good and the bad why
not report the
the death the decline of death like why
not report
they're good they never do because well
i i mean
we need envers like it's political now i
think moses is going to go away when the
election starts in november
i think a lot of it will too but we look
we've talked about this democrats doing
their best to we've
to you know it's it's a it's a trump
disease it's got baddies look at baddies
handle corona look at
look at the economy look kids aren't
back in school if he would have handled
it better so it's so political
i think in november when the election
comes by you know and because they look
notice they
they stop talking about florida really
new york's better
you know they're not talking about
sweden what happened to atlanta with
george all this so
they've they're running out of states to
talk about what happened in arizona or
in other cases
what about the hospital so they're
running out of things to
to go attack these days the president
also i think
in many ways made his own bet on this
one because i am not
uh a donald trump supporter
i'm not an apologist but i'm i'm i
consider myself a pretty objective guy
and
and i i think that there's so much
negative feeling and vitriol towards the
president
that people are just perfectly capable
perfectly
capable of relaxing their
view on logic in order to just continue
to gather bad evidence towards him
he's an emotional he's a polarizing man
and and that's that's his fault he can't
deny that regardless of polarization
well yesterday when they when they
they're giving corona updates and
fauci's not there because they
he doesn't agree with vouchers i don't
agree with that either but he's done
some good work but
uh and then he he talks about that lady
who
clearly a sex trafficker for epstein and
he goes i
i wish her well yeah what the [ __ ]
what do you mean you wish her well what
are you talking about i think
his bro this is speculation but he's a
man of science
he's a doctor yeah he is not skilled in
in the the world of like public oration
you're talking about faulty doctor yeah
you know what i'm saying that fauci said
i wish her no trump
trump and and so dr fauci he's like dude
i'm i'm a numbers guy
i'm i'm a i'm a binary person
and now i'm getting in front of a
microphone now he's famous tens of
millions of people at every moment are
listening
every and then hundreds of millions
subsequently you know in in retrospect
and he's probably everything that comes
out of his mouth he's like uh
all right you know but here's the thing
about falcon my only
my only thing about fauci is that he's a
very cautious man yeah
he's an incredibly cautious man which is
his nature but you would be as a disease
you can't have a guy you can't have him
you can't have him driving all policy no
no you just can't and
look you guys remember when you were
when t fat k was was a a corporate
entity right
you had you had a you had a umbrella to
answer to that was collecting paychecks
off of the work you do
they have their attorneys and their job
is to look out for the best interests of
them and making money and the bottom
line from a legal standpoint right
and we obviously we used to have the
same in radio
you had to run everything by these
corporate guys and these attorneys
because they're like
that'll probably get you in trouble i
know and and kevin and bean used to
bring me aside after and i and when
they'd shoot down some bit that i
thought was like
pretty innocuous and they're like you
gotta understand
what's the upside for them and their job
and their job
what's the upside for kind of fudging
and letting something fly yeah
very little what's the upside for just
playing it safe all the time
it's huge and i gotta see if you're a
public health official and your job
is the overall safety from a from a
medical standpoint
of the country economics socialization
uh a a growth of the gdp all that
[ __ ] aside you're just your number
one goal your prime directive
is keeping everybody safe what's the
upside i'm being like let's see how far
are we going to push yeah no he's going
to be pretty reserved and
i'm not trying to make excuses for the
guy because i'm definitely in line with
you where i'm
like man there's been a lot of mistakes
that are made that have cost people
people are destitute people are broke
people are are so depressed the suicide
rate is increasing
exponentially i've thought about it so
i'm i'm with you guys
but at the same time i'm also trying to
put myself in his shoes
he that's his bread and butter right
he's just playing it
just as americans you have to look at
all the data and [ __ ] live your life
yeah how you how old your kid right six
so she but
she's going to any schooling or anything
she we we she was at la
unified public schools last year in
kindergarten and
just this year prior to covet or
anything we decided to take her out and
put her in
um uh a private school because
um well she and she's she's she's a
weirdo my kid's a weirdo and i grew up
and i was kind of weirdo
not like off on her own talking in the
corner or no no just like
she's she loves her own outfits and has
no she doesn't care what other kids are
wearing she wears these [ __ ] up like
ace ventura when he goes to the mental
hospitals
that's cool and she she likes to create
this
insane artwork where an artist right and
a
good weird she's a weirdo she's not a
and she's wonderfully odd but but is she
an introvert
when she's not around like friends and
family yeah she's really introverted
when she's with us she's you can't shut
her up i bet
and i see so much of my daughter in
in me and i went to public schools
launified my whole life
i had 60 some kids in my class every
class you just massive schools
and i know that for someone like me
there was a big
one of the big reasons i was such a bad
student is because i was a shitty
student another reason was because like
i needed special attention
so my wife and i had this conversation
we're like we should get her in some
place that's a little more open-minded
blah blah
so we put her in this private school
covet hits la public schools are like
you're not going back to school we might
do some zoom
[ __ ] figure it out but this public
private school is trying so hard to kind
of toe the line they're trying the best
they can to say
you're gonna your kid's gonna go to
school in september it's gonna happen
but every week we get a [ __ ] news
newsome came out because yeah
my kids are in private school and they
you know the private school was allowed
to get away with it and
knew some realized that was going on and
he shut down that
it's it and schools are not allowed to
be open as of right now no
if they're in the if they're in one of
those hot zones yeah in california and
l.a county is one of them
but they keep sending cc's mail we have
five weeks we have four weeks there's
still so much we can do
so but you turned out fine you went to
public school i did but it was only by
the grace of god horrible drug issue but
i i and also
i i honestly like i don't know how it is
now
but in in big public schools there was a
time and a place
you know when i was in high school uh
and grade school
like there was a there was a an
understood
thing like smart kids who are
are on it go ahead pay attention you
[ __ ]
just keep your mouth shut we'll pass you
just stay out of my [ __ ] way and that
was like
they looked jimmy's number one don't
[ __ ] this up for the kids
and i and i very early on got this
impression that's like okay i'm that kid
and going to college and doing
white-collar work is not for me so just
[ __ ] do your best kill your time and
then hope to god that you can become a
fireman or
or uh get some like a good union
construction gig i had the worst
education because i was
moved all the time yeah so i just had
blinding gas i never get my father
i wrote a letter i wrote like a thank
you letter or something
and my father proof read it i was 15 and
he looked up at me and he said
are you worthy he just
the way you did he goes are you aware
that a sentence ends in a period i know
that's how [ __ ] idiotic that was
there yeah i did the same thing i wrote
the computer and i had my dad
proofreading he goes
i married he just your dad would be the
same i can't just see him he keeps going
like this and he
looks at me goes this is terrible i was
like um i was like
all right dude well [ __ ] sorry man
public school
dude i was reading aloud and i was going
like this i was going
uh the ski was uh blue and he goes read
it again
i know the ski was blue and he goes
read it again i got the ski is blue he
gets the sky
this guy god damn it he's pulling his
hair out because i was just sitting how
old were you an idiot were you like
i'll tell you what's interesting though
is like you know when your kids go to
school and you're you're driving them
and you know that takes time and then
you know they're at school and they get
home around four
you know now being home around my kids
so much it's like i get why
if you could come up with like a
curriculum where they could
learn at the home school and if you if
you have the freedom like we do with our
jobs to be around more you get more time
with them i can see the benefits of
homeschooling there's there's
huge benefits because you you can keep
your eye on your kid and then also
um there's always concern even if you're
not
some super conspiracy theory um you know
right wing [ __ ] there i i think that
there's obviously going to be concern
that like ethical and moral ideas are
going to be injected in your kid that
you don't think
you don't really especially the way
scientists are going right now right
exactly and then far left ideology
that's totally fair i think that's
totally yeah like far left
if you want to fire brian up bring it up
[ __ ] don't teach my
my kids your [ __ ] activist far left
idea of what you think truth is go [ __ ]
yourself reading writing arithmetic
sports
art keep your politics out of my [ __ ]
kids
i'm going to lose [ __ ] i know dude
columbus did discover america
believe me i'm going to come i'm going
to come after him i don't have any
problem with that
i don't have any problem with taking off
i'm certain like i don't have problems
taking on the idea of columbus
i learned that that columbus used some
pretty nasty [ __ ]
to get no they don't say any of that i
learned it in school
i didn't read yeah they taught that
where he gave the
native americans smallpox blankets sure
i learned that you
know
actually i learned that actually in high
school i didn't learn that
i think i think i'm with you on that
yeah but i mean look
look if you want to talk about i'd be
very happy for my children to
be exposed to the question should a
confederate flag be flying over the
capital of north carolina south carolina
and mississippi yeah or tennessee
are you i mean because that does stand
for slavery that's what that was
should a statue of robert e lee actually
be standing when he was fighting on the
side
of a pro-slavery army i get i
i think that's a very valuable
discussion to have and i i have
i have no attachment to the confederate
flag personally and
a statue of robert e lee mike my concern
with that though
homeschooling with any type of like
with any type of where you're trying to
indoctrinate
moral and ethical ideas on someone uh
whether it's at school whether it's in
the home or anything
i honestly think that that it's that's
not how it works
my point being is like you guys uh
either read or seen clockwork orange
right i just read the book okay i just
finished
so yesterday the whole point of the the
movie in the book
was was this one idea and i think so
many people
kind of see it as something else and and
for what i saw it was
was that they're they take this kid who
is admittedly
very ultraviolet you know he's a
sociopath
and then they take a government protocol
where they they try to
hammer in ethical and moral ideas well
they deal with
science right with what they look at as
a a system they give a system
i'm a drug and then they force them to
watch they give them a drug they shoot
him up with a drug the book is fantastic
but the movie's a
masterpiece what they did with language
is probably the second time
anthony purchased but they they shut him
up so they take they take him he's a
young
he's a droogie and he uh has his
three drugs uh dim peter and georgie
and his name is alex and they're from
he's got this
manchester accent and they go about and
they
rape and they kill and they maim
and his favorite thing for entertainment
the old ultra violence he calls it
where they and there are rape scenes in
that movie that movie is so shocking and
and
is he doing that stuff went before they
give him the drugs so yeah he's a bad
bad
he's a young okay he's a young drury and
he gets off on violence he's
so clearly a sociopath a sadistic
sociopath he gets off on destroying
human beings which he talks about
he gets arrested for killing an old
woman uh
he then is put into the system
and two years into his prison sentence
they say we have a cure
well this sounds like charleston so they
have him strapped to a chair and they
shoot him up with it with a
medicine they prop his eyes open in the
movie they have his eyes open like that
i remember that scene and they force him
to watch violent movies
and he starts to get sick when he used
to be turned on he gets sick he starts
to
throw up and so violence rape
all these things now even the thought of
it make him
wretch so this the the government has
cured him
but with the the theme of the book and
the theme of the movie is now you've
taken away choice you've taken away
moral choice
you've just made it impossible for him
to do good
bad things because you'll get sick but
you haven't you haven't changed the guy
you haven't changed and the argument the
argument is and of course
in the end and in the end it doesn't
really yeah in the end it doesn't really
work
in the end and in the book in the book
he actually gets oh he just grows up
and he goes you know i'm good destroying
isn't as good as creating and he just
gets older
but in in the movie there's a scene in
prison and i thought this was one of the
best little
pieces of spice that kubrick put on it
there's a scene where he's in the
library after this treatment spoiler
and he's dude the movie came out 50
[ __ ] years ago one of the greatest
movies
[ __ ] you you got a spoiler it's a it's a
mind blower um
it's a [ __ ] mind blowing there's a
scene where where alex alex has
has gone through this program and then
as brian put it he's physically
been changed but um he's he's you know
now living a life he's into studies and
he's wearing the uniform the whole thing
and he's in the school library and a
priest comes up to him and he says alex
how's it
how's it going and he says oh i'm i'm
right my right is rain sir and
you get all the good and uh the priest
says
okay i just want you to know he's like
he's he said he
bring brings me he said goodness comes
from within
goodness has to come from within it's
not something that can be applied to you
it's a choice and and
that's my big concern about all of this
too especially in the in this world
where we have like white fragility
and this id these ideas these ethical um
moral commandments that are being pushed
on people children and adults
not enough to be a racist now you have
to be anti-racist you can't be
you can't be a non-racist now you have
to be anti-racist so silence is racist
right well white silence is violence you
hear this stuff too
so these are the things i object to well
that and my point is
is that i had the incredible luxury of
growing up in
one of i honestly i'll take the pepsi
challenge with anyone i grew up in one
of the most diverse
places on the [ __ ] planet a a white
anglo-saxon was by far
the minority in in where i grew up and
i arrived at a point where i really do
feel that i am as as as enlightened as i
can
be to all separate cultures and that
wasn't because of any book i read
it wasn't because of any any type of uh
adult figure or or or or figure of
authority trying to
impose these ideas on me it was because
i had to live amongst people and talk to
them
and made mistakes and [ __ ] up put my
foot in my mouth and it clearly offended
people
then learned and then felt better about
myself when i understood people
then got turned on by the idea of
opening my mind to [ __ ] different
walks of life oh [ __ ] and and
and you can't you can't kind of
synthesize that
yeah in an intellectual because this is
what's dangerous this is what's
interesting about the cups
yeah let's thank you this is what's
dangerous about the narrative
the danger about the narrative when you
talk about white supremacy which really
means
this was a country that was founded by a
white majority so the culture is skewed
toward that
right so so when you say white supremacy
you're talking about white majority this
is kind of how cultures work
and then we work within that obviously
white people
suppressed native americans specifically
and black people obviously
and that has to be contended with no one
who wasn't but any time you start
pitting groups against each other
watch what happens is you're saying the
groups at the top are culpable
yeah and the groups at the bottom are
victims okay if you're going to do that
now what you're going to do is you're
going to say this you're not talking
about whites well now
now what about the asians the asians are
crushing it in every aspect
and and the jews and the jews so and we
know how that works out
we know exactly how that works out so
that you're going to have asians you're
going to have jews then you're going to
have whites
then you're going to have you know
latinos and and if you're going to
create trenches
a trench
i honestly i i really do appreciate you
even asking but yeah no i i
yeah it just hit me as a tiny bit much
less than that but okay
that's it the dashes dash dashes dash
that's it no it's very considerate to
even ask though uh 20 uh
18 years ago it would have been i would
have been like guys can we wait but
now it's not even a it doesn't even
change my heart rate um
it's true i mean like people talk about
white white um
privilege but i guess all the metrics
you would measure that by what would
they be
uh wealth um you know schooling kind of
things like that
asians are way higher than whites in
every one of them
and then so like where do we go they
didn't they didn't suffer any
short measure of discrimination
oh yes i i feel horrible because i grew
up in a really asian neighborhood wildly
simplistic
any time you find one bad guy which
could be systematic racism which could
be
white supremacy that's wildly simplistic
yeah it's a thousand things
it nobody wants to do the work but
anytime there's a problem
like say in the black community there
are a lot of issues they've had to deal
with
the loss of manufacturing jobs the loss
of agricultural jobs in in the 20s
um the crack epidemic the drug epidemic
housing
all of that stuff so many redlining
there are a lot of issues that you have
to take into account
and that's very important so you when
you while when you throw it all on
one bad guy yeah wildly simplistic not
gonna help
going back to what you were saying how
every former you know grandpas and
grandmas and great-grandmothers always
think that it's the worst time they've
everyone's lived through the worst time
the only argument that we're in the
worst time now is because of social
media and they cancel culture
they've never had to deal with that
you're talking about a different animal
yeah and that the narrative of that
canceled culture
which i think a lot of it it is white
people or
it you know doesn't matter race but i
think a lot of they they
they amplify everything because now we
got this you got to work
you can take away your because
corporations listen
the problem is that corporations are
gutless
and and sometimes they just rather
cancel you and just fire you well they
don't want to
there is recourse gutless in a way i
yes there's requests it sucks when
someone gets fired for something that
isn't even
actionable uh just because it looks bad
for a corporation but at the same time
again let's try and put ourselves in
their shoes if you support shoes
some corporation that fire someone or or
does something
for the sake of guarding their
reputation like cbs and
canada and nate you name it yeah um if
my job is i'm a uh i'm a senior vice
president of programming at cbs
and i know that i've worked for 30
[ __ ] years
doing everything i can to get up to the
ladder and now i put food on the table
for my kids by doing this job yes
and i i don't think i know
that the behaviors of one of the people
the behavior of one of the people or a
couple of people that i employ
could very easily cost everything
my whole company can go under is that
gutless or is that just well
sorry but let me know let me let me
let me well let me play devil's advocate
here let's say you are the person who
makes decisions at cbs
and nick cannon has worked for cbs
viacom for the last
20 years if you include nickelodeon 20
years and a grinder
by the way brilliant man brilliant man
he's made
zero mistakes in 20 you know this guy
he's a creator
he created wild and out he's made your
company a ton of money
he hosts you know mass singer on fox you
guys done a million things um
america got talent hosts all these shows
right wow all doing a morning radio show
in l.a
five days a week yeah hosting the
biggest morning race show in l.a so he
does all this stuff
he makes one mistake i don't agree with
any of it he [ __ ] up
boy did he [ __ ] there's a wildly stupid
comment eugenics
you're smarter than this you're smart
what he said he went out he went after
jews and white people
all right we but you know that guy for
20 years he's come up with all this
content he made one mistake
and you're the owner of cbs you guys who
run [ __ ] you're telling me you've never
made mistakes before okay so he should
be crucified off the
horrible mistake i don't agree with any
of it now if he came out and made an
apology it was like i realized what i
did wrong
i'm gonna study my history books i'm
gonna go back and learn how the jews
were prosecuting what they've done to
persecute
yeah persecuted and come over here and
the success that they've had i've
learned from my mistakes
20 years of work and because the one
mistake now he
should be [ __ ] voted off the island
you're right and and
one mistake what did he do specifically
bring up his exact quote nick because
you keep asking
yeah and you're it's doing you wrong
it's bad
he really brian he was like flirting
with eugenics like the idea that
white people are biologically you are
less than these people
white people white people are less than
black people
from viacom but uh fox actually he came
out with apologies
let me find the actual clip i can i can
sum it up i mean i i've gone over this
a couple times he essentially said that
the melon
the lack of melanin in the people who
migrated north to
to go to like the norse mountains and
things like that and then don't do it on
youtube
got more white um they are biologically
inferior to the people who are
better prepared to deal with the the
the sun and the earth and and living a
vibrant life
therefore they are the real savages and
that yet they
portray us as the savages
not great pigment on our skin and we're
the savages and white
people are evil and the
african-americans actually the original
they're the original jews
that's that's where i think he stepped
in and [ __ ] is that he the the the
melanin
not true but then he says we're the real
hebrews and that
then you're starting to get it here's
the other thing he did this podcast a
year
let me see where let me find her first
these are his apologies he did the
podcast a year ago you know that
like that was a year ago wow he banks
his podcast him a year ago so it came
out now
i i think maybe he uh he was like
reading the history books and all that
and he got
too deep into it you know what i'm
saying like on one subject but he
royally [ __ ] up i'm not saying he
didn't
i don't agree with anything he's a jew
of color
we said blacks are actually the real
jews you know that do you know that
do you know what that theory is it's a
theory about an evolutionary biology
theory
he read it out of a book about so so the
idea is as
our ancestors migrated from close to the
equator in africa
to northern climates you there was less
sunlight it's all about so
you need to lose the melon in your skin
so you can absorb more sunlight to
create more vitamins
now my hair stays in my head
because well brandon i use him
dude thank god how about this you need
help with hair loss
erectile dysfunction or have a cold how
about are you interested in mental
health or covenant 19 hometown what the
hell
yeah dude this is now just here yeah
nope
you're right yeah man
66 percent of men start losing their
hair by 35.
does it seem like your your forehead's
moving on up
well dude you got to keep what you have
it's you got to prevent your hair loss
right now thanks to science hair loss
can be
optional hims connects you to fda
approved products to treat hair loss
and they have thousands of happy
customers loving their hair
uh if approved you got to get approved
man if your approved products will ship
directly
to your door discreet little package i
got approved it took me five minutes
literally it's pretty easy i took a
picture and sent it to a doctor you're
right man hey anyone can make claims
about treating hair loss but if you're
not
happy after 90 days just email him for a
full
refund today hims is giving you the best
offer yet
if you're not happy with your results
after 90 days hymns will give you a full
refund and right now and it comes in
discreet packaging so nobody knows
you're getting haircuts yeah
yep listeners you guys can uh try it
free right now go to forehands.com
f a t k that's for hims.com
f a t k give them the disclaimer b full
refund of price paid available for over
90 days of supply
refund requests must be made between
90-180 days
after product shipment delivered
prescription products require an online
consultation with a medical professional
who will determine a prescription is
appropriate
restrictions apply see website for full
details and important safety information
become a customer i am and it works
still waiting for my wolf
they're going to send them i just got
word they're saying i need my whoop
bracelet i know we want to know
how i'm sleeping they didn't want us you
know they stopped they didn't set them
because we're both a little sicky poo
oh i want to know how i'm sleeping i
want to know what my recovery is about
check
i want to know what my heart rate is
doing when i'm sleeping when i'm
training how good
when i'm hanging out how many calories
are you burning i want to know how many
calories i'm burning are you getting the
right recovery i want to know how
how far i'm going do you want a device
that's going to monitor your heart rate
a hundred times per
second yes i do that's coming up with
all these calculations you're talking
about a little band you wear around your
wrist
how bad you want i don't know if i'm
being disturbed in my sleep i want to
know what the efficiency of my sleep are
you in the right amount of sleep
there's nothing better than whoop i'm
telling you dude i started because of
the thick boy bike club i was sick of
guessing how many calories i was burning
how far i was going
whoop came along i reached out to them
strain sleep
the hardware is easy it's a strap 3.0
five-day battery life this thing is
freaking waterproof you can swim with it
shower with it you never have to take it
off
looks pretty sweet they got different
colors different things you can pick go
to woop.com
promo code fighter all right you get 15
off 15 off go to woop that's w-h-o-o-p
dot com enter the code fighter at
checkout
save 15 off sleep better recover faster
train smarter
optimize your performance with whoop
thick boy bike club get your ass
a loop strap right now woop.com promo
code fighter
i i i do feel you guys know nick at all
have your message savages
he does say a lot of kind of kooky [ __ ]
cannon segways in disgusting skin color
and i'm going to say this carefully he
begins to allege that people who lack
sufficient melanin are a little less
those without dark skin have a
deficiency that historically force them
to act out of fear and commit acts of
violence to survive
they had to be savages jewish people
white people europeans among others
people on social media okay i mean uh
he he should probably brush up a little
bit more and talk to people like brett
weinstein about
evolutionary biology all of them all of
it he went down such a slippery slope
and he's been show business so long like
nick you're better than this
again i don't [ __ ] with anything he's
talking about he's
royally [ __ ] up but the body of work
over 20 years for cbs viacom
mtv you and he issues an apology which
his issue is he didn't want to apologize
at first but then he did apologize which
ended up [ __ ] because then the black
people are said
uh upset at him now yeah so you have the
jews and the white's upset then you
apologize and the black people are upset
you can't stick by it so you can't win
my only
thing is if you if you're running a
company you're telling me you've never
made any mistakes no it's
true it's critical the problem though
brandon has had it's that old joke it's
like
you can build a sistine chapel and come
up with a cure for cancer
but if you [ __ ] one goat
you're a ghost you're a ghostbuster dude
i mean
at the end of the day if you [ __ ] a goat
yeah i thank you for curing cancer and
thank you for [ __ ] sending a rocket
to them because it's not like
nick molested kids or murdered somebody
or raped somebody like those
yeah you should never work again but
cena
us a comet with no data no
obviously he's uneducated about what's
going on over his body of work and if he
could apologize on that
come on well and also i look i actually
kind of feel bad for the guy because i'm
i'm with you i i think what he said was
downright insulting especially if i was
a jew i was like blown away it was
clumsy
even though the white person pissed me
off imagine you're nick cannon all right
like like let's look at his career
guy works his ass off he does everything
he can to
to build his career all along the way
every [ __ ] step
the black community's been like that
guy's [ __ ] corny [ __ ] nick cannon he
sucks he's not
okay so you're like dude i gotta do
whatever i can to like
up my because i do legitimately think he
cares about the black community i don't
think he's one of these guys that's
fronting it
i think he's deeply deeply concerned
with like the welfare of the black
community
so the whole time he's like everyone
thinks i'm a [ __ ] corny
cornball i'm gonna do everything i can
to like ingratiate myself and prove that
i'm not i'm not a [ __ ] cornball i'm
just a guy who works hard and
uh you know likes to like speak my mind
so then you go and you get this
then corporate america is like well
you're [ __ ]
are you are you not gonna apologize well
then you do
and you you're [ __ ] yourself you know
financially maybe you're looking out for
yourself financially
but now the same black community who's
been picking on you this whole time is
like you [ __ ] sell out
yeah like what if you can't guy can't
win he can't win
it doesn't help that he was sitting
there talking to professor griff is that
that dude
yeah the guy who got kicked out of
public enemy for being too radical
like that guy's a [ __ ] [ __ ] i mean
he's essentially he's like richard
spencer but black
yeah he does not it was a perfect you
can change it by not
being by not saying
to taking groups and saying things about
those groups like they're savages or
animals or
that's not gonna work it's just not
[ __ ]
the the [ __ ] up he's the weird shot
and freud that comes with the the cancel
culture too that worries me so much man
because there's always there's already
pushback though isn't there
absolutely you're starting you're
already making fun of it yeah like
jeremy jimmy renner i think like the the
the accusations came out about him about
what what
nothing nothing like rape or anything
nothing like where it's automatic you're
done you know
but a lot of like uh his ex i don't know
his ex-wife are just ex
baby mama drug use in front of the kids
constant like sex parties just being
kind of like a slimy dude
and he's got apparently he's got a
substance abuse and everyone's
you know going the marvel needs to fire
him
thing you know or at least a group of
people are and disney's like no no
we're cool let's just hold off great
actor how about that i love that guys oh
phenomenal you watch her locker again
you might forget how [ __ ] he's
phenomenal oh dude
but i apparently he does town or yeah he
suffers from
i think he probably has some issues with
alcohol and drugs from whatever maybe
or through the
yeah he's very very smart guy have you
have you seen what's going on with
johnny depp in his case over and
so he's suing uh amber the sun because i
am heard because the sun came out
with this huge thing called my wife
beater he's like whoa hold the [ __ ] up
so he's doing
this so they brought amber heard in and
it's going well for johnny depp if
you're watching it yeah that is for
whatever reason i pay attention i read
the
the clips on it all the time yeah the
the problem with cancer culture in my
opinion this is speculation it's like
i sit back and i worry not because
people who
maybe are are feeling oppressed feeling
hurt
feel excitement in bringing someone else
down and feeling
like they have an active part in it
that's why they're doing it makes sense
i don't like it but i i get that what i
don't like and what i think is even more
concerning
is that this overall feeling of everyone
getting excited at the misfortune of
others
it's really sad and i don't think it's
just social media i think that
the real me like the actual mainstream
media plays a bigger role
um here's one quick example like i was
watching um
i never watched any of gordon ramsay's
tv until the um
the lockdown i just started watching
some of gordon ramsay's shows
and there's a hell's kitchen or some
other show where he goes in and he
talks [ __ ] to people who don't run a
restaurant right i just started watching
him too for whatever reason
and so they have this episode where this
guy's an [ __ ]
he yells he's petulant he doesn't want
to hear what gordon ramsay has to say
he's lazy he runs
and the editing and the and the show
creates this idea
through through through the way the way
they created the episode
made you just hate this guy and made you
want to hear gordon ramsay lay into him
yep
and i could feel myself going like yeah
get him gordon he's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
well because i'm watching them you know
now
years later they have the like extras on
the streaming services
i'm watching it he starts interviewing
him at the beginning
of before they start even going into the
restaurant and finding all these flaws
and he said yeah i uh my father passed
away very young and
he he was our only parent my mom died
too and so my brother raised me and he
got in the restaurant industry and he
was my hero and i modeled everything
wow everything around how my brother did
it and frankly he was the
he was the dad i didn't know how to run
a business but i just want to be just
like my brother
my brother died eight years ago of like
some free cancer
and so now i'm left here and i don't
really know how to run this restaurant
and you're like
oh wow yeah oh that that's but yeah but
but
fox or whatever production company said
we can't go that route
no one's gonna want to watch we got to
create this idea so that we stand up and
go
go gordon [ __ ] this guy up and i'm like
this is what we need to get away from
you're talking about that happening to
coordinator that happened the guy
that happened and and but yet if you
watch the episode you didn't
happen to like him for going to tandem
if my daughter didn't start screaming
for some reason and i didn't lost sight
of it and then this thing kept going and
i watched the [ __ ] extras which i
never would have watched
i would have had no idea and yet the
episode created this idea
for the sake of ratings for the sake of
getting people to watch the show over
and over again
that like no this man bad this man
terrible we should cheer on
gordon getting upset and stuff and and
it's i don't know i i
i we've talked about this before but i
used to work for cnn and hln
uh a while back and there was this
instance where i was on i'm not like a
confrontational guy but
one time i was on this is live tv and
there's this girl there she's a
reporter from you know bullshit.com
uh somewhere up in in the bay area and
there's this instance where
this man um it appeared to be homeless
who knows but he was he was clearly
not right he was walking through the
streets of san francisco with like a
machete okay obviously cops are called
can't have that cops call
um it's a group of cops uh a black
gentleman by the way the the machete guy
um a lot of damage mission machete very
very unfortunate
very unforgiving ask ms-13 they can you
can do some serious damage with a
machete yeah um cops come
try to gather around him and then they
uh initially like three or four cops
a couple of them black corral the guy
and half
happened to maybe you know throw him
down or whatever they can do to get
cuffs on him and take away the machine
very very appropriate he's lucky that
you just shot having a skating and shot
if i'm a cop i might have to shoot you
totally agree i'm thinking i don't know
[ __ ] about policing but i'm thinking in
my head i was like man that was a pretty
measured way to handle it they didn't
[ __ ] blast the guy he has a deadly
weapon was he naked dude
no no but he was he was usually
screaming and talking to himself you
know
and um this reporter is saying like and
and here we see yet again another
um example of white supremacy so
i i absolutely lose my cool and i start
screaming at her and i mean like vayne's
coming on my neck on live television
type move and it goes on the crowd's
cheering everyone's yelling and
everything
and i sit back down we go to commercial
break and i'm like [ __ ]
i'm like i [ __ ] up i really [ __ ] up
and this this girl had to be like 21 or
something and i'm dum-dum
shark right maybe i i maybe intellectual
stuff aside i'm like
i shouldn't have done that and i and i'm
like man i'm probably going to get a
talking to you from the producers i'm
like
this is not good so we go to commercial
break i go over and i'm like i'm sorry
i don't i totally don't agree with you
but i i shouldn't have done that that
was wrong and an
apology she's like it's okay i thank you
for saying that did you get in her face
no we were we were 10 yards apart but
i'm literally like
that's fine are you [ __ ] considering all
the real white supremacy in the world
think about what emmett till's family
has to think about that when you're
calling policemen doing their work
good you know right you know yeah and i
i still think i'm right but
my point being is like totally lost mike
was a man yeah
i get off with the show ends uh i get
back to the green room to take off my
makeup and the executive producer comes
in
and i'm thinking like oh here he goes he
goes dude
oh that's what i'm talking about okay
and i'm like
what he's like that's television here we
go you know it is
so two months later uh we have uh
it was like a explosion of right when
caitlyn tran uh transferred over into
what bruce wayne bruce who went to
caitlyn so there was a lot of transport
we had a a um a trans activist and then
also
uh some religious figure i don't know if
he's a priest or a pastor but he was a
man of the cloth
and he was on there and he uh
disagreed with me and disagreed with
this activist but at the same time was
incredibly measured very kind and was
everyone was kind of talking he
disagreed that
he should be able to oh i just thought
that trans
that it wasn't a mental silence
he was going the the kind of traditional
religious route that
a man is a man a woman is a woman you
can't change that blah blah blah okay
i was having some disagreement with him
this lady was having some disagreement
with him
but everything was very civil and
actually very and he was really
likable and nice i'm like oh that was
that was really great i hope more people
saw that because you could see that you
could have disagreements and
and it would be civil i get off i go to
take out my makeup [ __ ] executive
producer comes in he's like
we can't we can't be having you back if
that's all you got
i go dude he's like come on babe we're
we're in the ratings business yeah we
need we need to fight and and to just
it lets you know like on on one level or
whether it's whether it's abc or whether
it's back of the
nation but here's the truth so you know
he's
like all the time we talk about corona
yeah when the rubber is a little better
when rubber hits the road
at the end of the day actually the truth
is there is
there is your position there is there
that person's position
and sometimes there is no compromise so
let me give you an example
there's a woman who just did rogan she
did she wrote a book called irreparable
damage
you got these 15 year old girls who are
cutters
who are suicidal whatever it is and some
of them decide that they're trans
so they can go to planned parenthood and
they can get
testosterone and then planned parenthood
can send them to a surgeon to lop off
their breasts
now from what i understand in some
states you don't have to tell the
parents
and you don't have to be 18. they're 15.
so you got a 15 year old whose
prefrontal cortex isn't even developed
yet right and
because we have activism now in planned
parenthood
what what that that this is where you go
oh well you're 15.
so you want you think you're a man well
that's amazing and we support you
as opposed to hold on you're 15.
you're going through this thing you've
decided at this point
maybe you feel like you're a man yep who
knows what's going on in your head but
you're 15. and the reason that we can't
have
people making those decisions for
themselves when they're 15 is because
they're children they're 50.
they're minor and their brain isn't
fully difficult i want to be real you
may feel like a man or you may feel like
a woman or whatever
i can't allow i can't allow you to take
those that kind of irreparable
um that kind of irreparable action
because you might change your mind yeah
yeah i mean look you can't get attached
to until you're 18. but the problem is
this is
this is where activism comes in and
starts [ __ ] with your own children
where they will say you're not allowed
to tell your parents
that's where i [ __ ] draw the line and
i go nah that's a line i'm willing to
fight for yeah has nothing to do with
transgender
yeah it's called irreparable damage and
this woman who wrote this book as a
reporter
she nobody will have her to have nobody
have it on the podcast why
because this whole trans thing is
so electric apparently [ __ ] off i'd have
her on i mean i want to have her on here
but
well i mean she might you know because
it's not it's not our audience well
what'd she look like
i mean hey what what the hell i'm just
saying that that
she's a but according to rogan she's
very smart very smart very very good
journalist but yeah but anyway so there
the thing is that
the thing is at the end of the day we
all have our positions and we all have
our lines we're willing to fight for and
it gets sticky
it gets [ __ ] sticky the whole thing
stick it like i was listening to
clay travis shout out to clay travis
listen to him talk about
um how politics are coming into sports
now
so espn for whatever reason every day is
talking about black lives movement not
that it's not important
but people aren't tuned in for espn the
nba nfl
they don't want their politics in their
sports they just want to watch the
sports
but when all you're doing is covering
all this stuff and the protest on stuff
you know what happened the ratings of
espn have never been lower
well that's that's what the marketplace
the market is like dude
i want to watch it i want to talk about
in fairness to the great thing about
sports is they're not political the
great thing about sports that brings
everybody together no black white but
the promise now is like it's such a hot
topic in america
so in the nba now instead of having
their last names on their jersey
they're going to have black lives matter
or a spiritual quote back there
so you're you're mixing in you're you're
blurring the line here here's
and here's the problem with that people
don't want to hear it i i think in
general overall
you're totally right i mean if i turn to
espn i want to
find out what happened to you know
gilbert over the weekend in the fight
i don't want to hear about much anything
else i want to get my sports but at the
same time
i gotta cut sports network some slack
right now sports radio as well
what else are you gonna talk about you
know what i'm saying like if it's a
regular life
scenario i'd say but they'll learn too
that at the same time look americans are
what they are it's the american story
against americans are like black white
asian doesn't matter they're all like i
want to watch sports you're talking
about this too much
it's like anything else it's how we have
to respond well you start talking about
covert people like
shut the [ __ ] up about covenants we want
to hear dick jokes yeah well think about
colin kaepernick when he was doing this
whole thing ratings went down
cause we were like wait what you know
we're just trying to watch the games man
well ballers is interesting because when
i was yeah
it's old you just got no hold on baller
ballers is an older show when was the
last time ballers was on the air
1948 but it was a while ago but in
ballers
uh toward the the last season the fourth
season in fact
they're talking about black lives matter
they have sneakers with it on
they're talking about the kaepernick
thing they're talking about taking a
stand as a black athlete it's pretty
interesting
because when that was waiting for all
this stuff no no this
this this first episode 2015 ended in
2019
so they were dirt they all they're doing
is copying what's going on guys
if you're if you i am i'm not mr race
card guy and i hate to
do that so race car guy race card i'm
not the guy who
wants to play racial politics and there
i i'm i'm very
upset by a lot of these uh unnecessary
kind of
waves that are being made but i will say
like i i read this book about step and
fetch it
you do you know who that is i know you
might he's a race car you know he was
like he was he was uh uh uh
entertainer in like the 30s and for a
black entertainer
and he was at the time one of the
highest paid actors in the world but he
was a black american oh that's cool
but and he was this incredibly talented
hills incredibly talented guy
but he wrote a book and then had to look
back on his life where he had
to do all to to become this amazing
american success
he had to have a bunch of white studio
execs tell him now now dude
hello there let me go you know
essentially doing his own minstrel act
and i got to thinking like if you're a
20 year old black kid right now and you
make it to the nfl or the nba it's like
how far from that
from step and fetch it situation is is
your situation where it's like
you've probably had been [ __ ] on by by
the corporate will not not not even
bringing race into it just the idea of
like
the the the structured society has just
[ __ ]
[ __ ] put their their their to these
athletes your neck your whole if you're
a young black kid from an inner city
neighborhood
or a poor neighborhood your whole life
has been just been [ __ ] people
just providing adversity for you then
you make it now you're a millionaire
people are applauding you all the time
and then you have to keep getting
corporate edicts on how you can like
behave and think and feel about social
and political issues sure
i'd be like okay you know what [ __ ] [ __ ]
you [ __ ]
everyone yeah you know the same thing
goes back it's like the people who
sitting
sitting back in their couch saying i
just want to watch football i don't know
if they do that i don't the only thing
is that no
no business in the in the history right
of
the united states i don't know about
international but the united states has
created more millionaires than the nfl
or nba yeah in african-americans
no it's it's and also you're you're
working for a corporation so anytime you
work with any corporation there's going
to be
certain protocols you have to observe
right there's a dress code there's a
there's a code of conduct that you have
to observe the nfl is very strict
yeah about all kinds of [ __ ] like that
you know so no everyone's working for a
company
right everyone's worked for a company
you understand that it doesn't matter
what you can do what's
what's free for you to do in this
country
if i promise to pay you money you're
going to do exactly
when you work for netflix or a company
like that i promise you there are
certain things and a lot of things you
can't say out loud
yeah you can't you can't email out it's
weird too
tweet and today i know this in today's
world of like multimedia where everyone
even a-list stars have like 11
you know projects going it's really
strange how let's say you have a big
deal with netflix
i i don't know this for a fact but let's
use him as an example let's say bill
burr right
they're paying him a lot of money to do
a tv show at netflix it's weird how a
lot of their
um code of conduct can bleed into his
other
work yes where they're like you can't go
making i'm not saying this happens with
bill burr but
he's an example um you can't say so and
so in your
comedy stand up or you can't go do a
podcast where you
talk about this issue because we're
giving you seven million dollars so
and it's like really what i don't work
for you over here
you know that that's that's a little
it's a really weird thing the good news
is that
for the most part you can say whatever
the [ __ ] you want you can't though
i mean really you're gonna depending if
you're if you're a comic you sure as
[ __ ] can't yeah no you can't yeah you
can't no way if you work for a
corporation
no way if you work for if you work for
netflix if you have a big podcast that's
what i'm saying
if you're just collecting your checks
going around the country going to comic
comedy if you're
so you guys you can do whatever you want
you guys are the last
last hope for like the idea of the
american idea of like you know
of like mark twain or or great thinkers
because it depends what truly
depends what you want if you're a bill
burr if you're especially the best
examples or a good friend joe rogan
rogan can do whatever the [ __ ] he wants
to do he has [ __ ] you money
outside that there's not you know here
you gotta remember i work for
showtime i work for a complex i you know
i i still have to i don't have [ __ ] you
might as well go watch my piecing but i
would say this i would say this
um i'm not allowed to say things i
wouldn't say anyway a lot of times right
so
so what i mean by this is this i don't
say things that are
like anti i don't say racist things
never thought they were funny i don't
make jokes like that
i never liked doing no they're not funny
but what i'm saying is that we don't do
that anyway you wouldn't be you
i wouldn't right i'm not your boss
racist comedy it's [ __ ] straight
funny and can be useful well dude if
it's like dave chappelle
joke about about yeah i'm a little
racist like if i walk into a pizza joint
and it's a bunch of black women making
my pizza
i'll be like all right well maybe this
is maybe i should keep walking and just
see if there's another pizza
that's [ __ ] genius but that that's
all funny but but
at the end of the day i i think the
things that you're not allowed to say
when i see like this nick cannon stuff i
don't say that [ __ ] anyway
mainly because i don't want to hurt
anybody it's not who you are i just
don't want her
but i think there's a freedom with a guy
like rogan or you know i think
chappelle's the best comic to ever do it
there's a freedom with chappelle
where you're not going to cancel them so
like when you watch a special you might
like oh he's going to get some hot water
for that
he doesn't give a [ __ ] what are you
going to do yeah
corolla's a good example corolla's a
great example you if you listen to what
corolla says
carol if you're if you're if you're not
a cro if you're anti-corona bro so those
people who
think corona is the end of the world and
the economy should be shut down for the
next five years and
we should all lock down our house it's
only get worse if you're that dude
you don't listen to corolla don't listen
to uh clay travis because those guys
don't answer to a boss
and they give you facts and just shoot
from the [ __ ] hip like when corolla
starts sticking up for jimmy
kimmel there's nothing better man
because you can tell they're best
friends it'd be like if you were going
through the same [ __ ]
corolla just [ __ ] sticks it to him
yeah he's correct intent matters too
though i also go for kimmel
me too intent matters a big deal like
if someone puts on blackface for the
sake of putting on blackface to harm
someone to hurt their
that's that's honestly the most
repugnant that's one of the more
republicans
i just wouldn't want to right i mean you
understand you're saying
i'm going to put on a costume that
brings terror to people that reminds
people
of years and years of of oppression now
if you're
painting your skin black so that you can
better resemble carl malone yeah that's
a big [ __ ] difference
but that's what's going to be exactly
that goes back to my point mike it's
like
let's look at the body of work of jimmy
kimmel for the past
20 years man has he ever say anything
racist has he done any of that racist
[ __ ]
no and then you point towards this one
car malone skit that he did
which was funny yeah but you know i i
guarantee if you ask him to do it now
he'd never do it or how about fallon
dude he did blackface making fun of his
friend chris rock christopher
[Applause]
um they're not they're not racist like
uh when nobody's looking and they don't
do it like
think about it for a second like to be
mean
and to be that ignorant i don't really
want you around you're you know that
this is
most of us right i mean here's the thing
absolutely i
remember said to rogan i said one time
when he was like 28 and he was a [ __ ]
boston kid
you know like like when nanette that
that that hannah gatsby came out and
said
straight white men better pull their
socks up because i got the [ __ ] beat out
of me because i was gay
i don't know a [ __ ] straight dude i
i'm serious
i don't know a [ __ ] straight dude
that i would hang out with who was a
friend of mine
that wouldn't have come to her defense
if if if any of my friends
saw hannah gatsby getting the [ __ ]
kicked at her by some [ __ ]
dude i would [ __ ] that dude i'll beat
him i gotta be honest we'd be like
you're beating up this woman who's gay
any woman she's gay i'd [ __ ] stomp
you i wouldn't
i wouldn't realize that she was gay i'd
be stomping on your [ __ ] hand
but most of my friends stupid face right
one time one time bro
then i'd come at you i'd practice my
residual
i thought he was a bro from boston i
said you know i've never heard you say a
prejudice thing and you're a
boston jersey guy you know and he just
goes
it's so funny he goes because i'm not a
[ __ ] idiot like what do you mean he
goes
i i grew up i lived in boston new jersey
you want to see really dumb white people
i'll take you to see really dumb white
people too because well dude never mind
bill burr's life is black
kid is half black right it's like but
you know kimmel's gonna lose his job
you think yes okay he's going to lose
his job over that mm-hmm
he's on he's on break right now do you
know that cancer is ready
castle culture's real they're letting
them bow out with grace
ah you want to bet he okay he'll find
another i don't know i don't know
if he'll find another job i mean oh yeah
on what network
i mean he would maybe do the manchester
with corolla he can go on a podcast and
make millions of dollars
abc nbc cbs ain't going to hire him
because
do you think so maybe let's say you'd
say you're right and he
he he is released from his job as host
of jimmy kimmel
don't you think that there would be
such a huge groundswell of support for
him in his next job
because the the really the population
of people that get crazy over really
unreasonable stuff
like this small it's very small and i
think they're the loudest
instagram and i think people on twitter
if kimmel then went to
uh a podcast or or a netflix show
that people will be like oh he's that
guy who didn't apologize and said hey i
wasn't
being raped i was i know i know i'll
fall in love and i just think that maybe
there would be
especially nowadays where everyone feels
so persecuted by everything who doesn't
like
who does i think he's the best host
there is super nice who wouldn't follow
him he's always been
get him on the podcast i would follow
him but i don't think he's doing a lot
of podcasts right now having some issues
um why not i got punked by trying to
stick up for a woman by the way i just
reminded me when you said that
all for she was like getting slapped
around you stuck out you got slapped
around very
not all not that i didn't get slopped
around but i do i definitely
turned into a [ __ ] i i was driving this
wasn't that long ago
i was driving home ironically from muay
thai i was driving home
and uh i'm pull up to um
rose and lincoln in venice there's that
whole foods there yeah and behind it
there's like the loading dock and i'm
just driving like at a stoplight and i'm
just minding my own business getting
ready to go home
and i look over and these two homeless
people arguing
not at all surprising or new for venice
california
all of a sudden it's a guy and a girl
and all of a sudden he just
[ __ ] boom she's [ __ ] front kicks
right to the chest johnny this is venice
right to her chest and she
falls down whoa so i without even
thinking i almost
impulsively i i threw my car in park and
i i got i was like hey
and he turns around and he goes like and
his like
[ __ ] missing teeth and [ __ ] and he
wasn't like big guy but
like he turned and he looked like a
zombie you're gonna have your hands full
and not only that
in my mind in the in a matter of a
second all these thoughts go through i
was like
am i really gonna put hands on this guy
who definitely has diseases
polio and you know and this is pre or
prior to covid or anything but then i'm
like
really what am i am i going to just head
kick him and hope for the best and run
away
and then i was like hey be cool
you can't do that that was like
by the grace of god there's some uh
dudes who worked for whole foods in like
the loading and and
they had their little walkie-talkie
things and they come over and they're
like
we're calling the cops right now we're
going good he's like [ __ ]
[ __ ] and he just runs away but in my
heart like was the girl i thought i was
jason
and then i was like i do what do you
want anything i'm thinking like i'm the
man i'm gonna go over i'm gonna help her
did you think she's jesus yeah eat [ __ ]
i do you want better
my buddy is your friend in france
studying muay thai
my buddy george and his buddy and his
friends really like
taking it very seriously and they're in
paris beautiful city
sure and there's a guy attacking a woman
against a car
and uh my friend's buddy
goes over and goes i do muay thai kicks
him in the [ __ ] leg
elbows him punches him the guy [ __ ]
falls down but
the guy's not that good he's not that
athletic the guy goes what the [ __ ] are
you doing
and the guy he was hitting was the
brother
of that woman who was having a diabetic
seizure
and he was trying to hold her down and
control her
and so oh my god yep and that guy went
to the hospital
and so my friend my friend's friend
brought him flowers every day
and said sorry but he was in the
hospital for three days [ __ ] uh but you
know so you got to be careful yeah you
definitely she was having a diabetic
seizure it was just like
my [ __ ] sister she's having in like
regular life
i've gotten in so few physical
altercations
but i can so rarely think of any that
went well for me
like yeah one one time i i absolutely
uh hit a home run with my face and
totally cheap shot at him
but it was worth it um and i still feel
totally
good in doing it and i've told this
story on the air enough that i now feel
comfortable saying
without getting like charges brought
against me but
prior to marijuana being fully legalized
in california it was just medical stuff
so in venice there there's just tons of
dispensaries
and they all had these guys who were out
in front like trying to promote
their said go get your medical card come
get your medical card
and there's this guy he was big he
wasn't in good shape but he was big
person he big kind of fat and uh he's
like hey man get you
come get you your medical card and i'm
walking my dogs i was like i'm i'm okay
man it's cool and he's like oh what what
you got you got that
pink lugs little [ __ ] got pink lungs
and i'm like uh no i just
a little [ __ ] yeah and it's a saturday
in summer in venice there's
thousands of people around yeah and i'm
like i know i i just don't
smoke weed so he's like oh yeah you
don't speak you're not man enough to
smoke weed dang ain't got any head on
your chest
and and he starts now he starts doing
like a like a defensive back
if i'm a wide receiver i'm walking like
this and he's like this
like as i'm trying to cut you off yeah
watching your hips and so
i got i got like uh
overwhelmed with like almost like fear
like this guy's trying to figure it
out yeah and so i put my dog's leashes
into my left hand
and i just went wham and just cracked
him
full swing as he's looking away trying
to get people to
pay attention to him punking me and i
just cracked him
not even over here not even looking at
me and i just [ __ ] cheap shot and
right
and he did i didn't knock him out but he
fell down and i could tell he was seeing
his stars like and i go did you run away
and i go oh my god i just committed
felony assault in front of thousands of
people and i
take my start sprinting away it was like
those signs you see when you're going to
mexico where the
family's getting dragged behind my poor
dog's like and i just ran away and i
went home and i was like oh [ __ ]
and i never told anybody about for like
a year and then i went on love line
up and i was waiting a fat guy if it's a
fat white guy
i'm not gonna be intimidated yeah if
he's samoan yeah
i'm gonna be afraid i'll tell you i i
i'd never get in a fight
publicly the closest that if i ever do
gonna fist the cuff ever
is on the bike trail these bikers it's
not mountain bikes mountain bikers are
great mountain bikers
they got they stay in their lane
everyone does their own [ __ ] it's the
people in the tight spandex and they're
on like
the road bike but it's on the mountain
bike they just for whatever reason they
always yell at people
or you know you shouldn't have your
headphones in the yell if you don't have
a mask on like they always say something
that's that's
and especially like if i'm going through
something someone yells i'm like god
dude there's nobody around but what do
you think
you would do somebody if you had to
fight a guy like that would you
choke him or squeeze him or would you
punch him i'd punch him right in the
face you would
yes and then get on my bike i'd take his
bike
i'd throw it off the mountain and then
get on mine and keep going
who's the guy though that when you i'm
telling you oh
dude all the time because that guy's got
if you do not every time i write they're
on their bike to say
something take your headphones off
what you have to do is go look at my
ears it's not going to work out for you
that's it no i just pretend i don't hear
them i keep going but every
it's only those guys in the the in the
spandex and like the right
there was a guy in marina del rey i used
to see i'd be walking my dog this
[ __ ] guy
probably 50 very big
very good shape bald head looked like a
like a cop of some kind and such a dick
he was right he would ride people
he's just he was got to be probably six
four but with those long legs just
you'd have your hands full and he was
such a dick and he was in there
he would always be in his bike and cars
are going hey
[ __ ] face watch yourself and he was so
aggressive
and every day i'd have my dog and i'd be
like i would have to fight him
brian keller would have to fight him i'd
have my hand full might get myself still
but i just hated him so much it's a
special kind of person to speak i'm like
yeah i was like just
bullying just get your work out shut the
[ __ ] up right well it's like
there's there's one trail i go down it's
you go by this cool it's in santa monica
mountains you go by
they have this old world war ii post
it's dope
it's it's way high and then you go down
the mountain and then to the left is the
bike trail where
it is straight for biking no one walks
it everyone knows the bike trail
you go up and it's down there's jumps
and like it's fantastic
and this dude's walking with this hot
ass shoe so hot that's how i noticed
them
they're walking hand-to-hand and they're
on the middle of the bike trip with a
bite it's a single track
i can't go left i can't go i don't want
to die so i'm like watch out and the guy
was like [ __ ] you bro
we're walking here and i'm just looking
i'm like what
what he's just i'm like what are you
thinking dude
what's gonna happen man if i if you
you've probably talked [ __ ] like this
your entire life and no one's ever done
anything that's that's why you're doing
it that's
why i jump off this bike man you know
what i don't know
i think part of like training in
anything like yesterday
malik was holding mitts for me and then
he started hitting me back with the
mitts
and what i realized i don't know this is
going to be shocking to you is that
i'm not able to do anything against him
when he starts doing that because
he can hit me everywhere and he's been
doing it since he was seven
and when you do that with a guy who's
what's malik 165 yeah and then
and he can kill me yeah and then i look
like this yeah but he can knock you the
[ __ ] out no
no with his [ __ ] hands and then i
look at you and i go
when when you're a regular dude and
you've been training and you see those
ears and you see the size and you go
oh that's going to be a disaster that's
not good
don't take all the take all the ufc take
all that away
but just it could be anywhere i agree
dude why don't be that
disrespectful you don't know who you're
[ __ ] no you're just but also like you
you saw me coming a mile away just step
to the side dude
why say he might be why do you want
problems well that guy that guy
that definitely doesn't train and
secondly
has never really got his ass no because
you you just you you
learn quickly i i'm i'm not
uh advocating violence and i'm not even
good at fighting
but what i will say is that there is a
very clear-cut
very very useful kind of night and day
uh learning experience from being
physically humbled
that it's way better than being like
ridiculed like
every guy should i don't i don't want
people to end up in the hospital but
like learn talk [ __ ] get hit like if you
don't learn that
you know your whole life you're like
you're just gonna keep doing it and i'm
you know you're in a fancy area you know
santa monica palisades so i'm sure
everyone no one's just gonna expect
they're gonna sue you well it's like
for whatever reason i sent you in rogan
pictures and i post on my instagram dude
i saw four rattlesnakes crazy
and i was like what the [ __ ] is
happening one was big and it was like
this cool
blue brand you call it a dirt noodle uh
dirt serpent
what do you call it a danger noodle it
was that's what i used to call
dude it makes sense yeah it was big it
was like this big
that one right there and it was like a
cool blue
and there's is it a rattler or is it
something else oh that's a rattler papa
wow
he's a cool blue that's a beautiful you
hear me at the end she goes thank you
whoa
that's a beautiful isn't that cool i
love seeing them now
they don't really scare me but four of
them was like what the [ __ ] is going on
but you hear the lady um watch she goes
thanks i got no problem
because she's she's coming right i see
these titties flopping right she's
coming
i see these tits like this she rubber
she's impossible tits like this
right and then i see the snake and i and
she's coming straight for it
and i'm like this she's like i'm like
this and she's like
and i i'm pointing like he's come he's
starting at the front and she's gonna
run right into him
and i'm like this i'm all snake snake
and she goes she goes
what are you there you don't see the
giant rattle saying she goes
oh they're harmless i think yeah all
right
she was so mad i interrupted her jog i
was like what the [ __ ]
that's not true by the way they're
harmless i'm like oh you're a [ __ ]
okay i it's it's so strange like
when people are entering into danger not
because they're
fearless or they're tough or they're
courageous but because they so have no
idea what they're talking about
like that that bothers me a lot it's a
gorgeous snake man
well that's a different that was a
different one anytime you see them i
stop dude look at that
yeah they're fascinating they're
actually fascinating that big one it was
like this weird like metallic blue and
black they're
they're so cool looking i mean obviously
you don't want to [ __ ] they're western
diamondbacks i think right yeah they're
so
are there different rattlers around here
is it all western diamondback
uh southern california has gnarly
critters gnarly
i mean nowhere in the no we're not in
the uh
australian ballpark but we have some
gnarly but as far as
uh us goes think right at the top in
arizona and florida
well i'll tell you what it's weird is
there's one part i go down where it's
single track
and it it's like rock and it turns in
like a little bit of a black top and
you're flying
sometimes you'll see a big rattler just
like
soaking up the sun oh and it's like dude
what are you gonna do
a lot of different kinds of snakes and
it's like it's kind of cool that it's
you know
four pounds and it you get so scared of
it you know like a bear
yeah okay i'm scared my [ __ ] baby
that thing is
less than a chihuahua and it will [ __ ]
if it bites you it's trouble
is that what it said was that what rosie
boa can you come back up or the one
above yeah they have them in southern
california
it says california snakes wow the the
first
rattlesnake ever saw i posted it dude
that was huge it was an anaconda yeah it
was a ralph sync anaconda
i was so [ __ ] scared what is that
racer
constrictor pretty cool snakes you ever
see a mountain lion up there
no i lied to brian said i did i really
did
you saw one you did i saw a bobcat
scared the [ __ ] out of me i used to ride
horses
at the sunset ranch by the hollywood
sign a friend of mine taylor
um entrusted me to take care of his
horse he's a real cowboy
and he trusted me to take care of his
horses while he was in the police
academy and i was
more than happy to do it i got this
crash course and like how to really take
care of a horse and really ride
clean their shoes the whole thing so one
day i take
this horse molly out and uh the the the
kind of foreman there had told me he's
like
you can't go down you can't go for ride
after sundown because there's the
the cats they come i'm like shut up are
you serious he's like
he's like yeah they are big they they
are very these horses are very scared of
them too
i go whoa what well i have no choice i
work until
6 p.m i sometimes i got to come he's
like if you see him
you'll jump off your horse and i go [ __ ]
you
i have a 1200 pound yoked out animal i'm
gonna jump off it he says no he will
confuse the
the animal and he will scare you that
makes sense
and i'm so i'm thinking i'm like maybe
this guy's [ __ ] with me right
sure enough come around the corner one
night i'm right and i'm all by myself
and i turn the corner in it's a pitch
star no no it was like dusk
but it was like um like 30 meters away
and you see
and you're like whoa that's way bigger
than i thought they were how big oh yeah
150 pounds yeah like like the biggest
dog there is
and just much bigger and and and yeah
like like
like jack francis and ganu animals right
yeah
so i go shoulder and i always kept
a knife in my boot at uh the
the the blade yeah people told me to do
that i said you could get tied up in the
stirrups it's always good to have just a
knife to cut yourself loose from
so i always kept one in my boot and i
and i i thought about was like i said
and i pulled it out like i jump off the
horse and go
and the thing like calmly looks at me
turns around and walks away really
i go whoa jesus beastmaster [ __ ]
and of course the horse is sitting there
like okay yeah you because my my initial
reaction would get on stay on the horse
and just
turn around and [ __ ] sure dust off
yeah but the the horse is scared
shitless too so you never know if you
can
be horses sound like they're there and
i'm bi i'm not
even like an advanced writer so i mean
yeah exactly you know maybe something
like this ever hear a mountain lion
scream
no [ __ ] bring it up on youtube
they can scream i i see it if i ride
early enough i'll see a lot of coyotes
bobcats [ __ ] ton of rattlesnakes
coyotes are shitty animals [ __ ] kaido
yeah kylie's a bad people
dude that's from hell that's
are they fighting that's there's that
cop that's scary go go go back
we won't be able to play into this by
the way oh no no i'll play this like a
tiny example let's let's that reminds me
i'd want to run something by youtube
you're both uh
clever smart you know deep thinking
fellas
i'm not by any stretch of the
imagination mr
wild tinfoil hat guy you know i i like
sam tripoli very much but i'm not the
guy who thinks about the
alternative ways of of life and i
certainly
don't disagree with evolution or science
in any way sure
i'm too dumb to even [ __ ] come up
with some idea but i was thinking the
other day
i was watching tv and they were talking
about
the how impressed scientists are with
the development of these great apes
and that that is the second in line as
far as intellect in the animal kingdom
the humans obviously on top
the next thing is these great apes and
they were showing them doing this thing
where
they can a light would flash in a
pattern like simon says
and then they would do the [ __ ]
pattern yeah and i'm like
that's number two that's [ __ ] number
two
there's a billion species and they all
kind of go like this
then there's this utterly monster
monstrous gap between us
and numbered this thing they're so
impressed by
the fact that it can follow a pattern
that is right i watch spacex
go into space and land where they wanted
it to land
a little smarter what okay a little
smart we aren't we learn
how but octopus how is there there
there's only one big debate they've been
the same since they showed up
exactly beings have what's called
potential it's the fundamental
difference between
animals as we know them and human beings
but white beings
have imagination and potential to become
whatever their mind's eye can see and my
my question is
including beyond their own uh evolution
why
only one species and there is this
there is this incredible gap of time
where even the smartest archaeologists
and
and and scientists and evolutionary
scientists they go yeah somewhere around
five thousand years ago when they know
between five thousand fifty five hundred
years ago
the the pyramids were erected you're
getting into they can't explain
how the pyramids are the way they might
be a simulation because you're getting
into questions that now
physics and religion are trying to
answer which are questions like
human beings might be self-replicating
machines already
we might we have this insane ability to
create uh not only our own reality but
go beyond our own biology and our own
evolution we're starting to be able to
control our own evolution
have you seen the have you been
following the uf ufo stuff
a little bit confirmed the ufos and all
that yeah that one that that where they
actually confirmed it
but my dad and they're saying kind of
like you know the
the uh the science and technology that
these
ufos have is so much more advanced well
it accelerated not only accelerated with
speed but in in
height change something that's
bizarrely physically and then and the
temp they said they estimate
it's going 240 miles an hour but just
chilling i think able to go any
direction
and then also you know the the way our
uh fighter pilots were able to pick it
up because people were like oh it's a
bird but the way
our system works it doesn't pick up uh
animal life yeah it picks up only
solid like metal objects or whatever
that's how the system works that's it's
also
the temperature of it was minus like a
hundred like it was
basically it'd be frozen if it if we
knew if it was on earth
that that's crazy that type of [ __ ] is
is mind-blowing especially because
for the first time we're getting it from
a really really
well vetted kind of naval officer and a
pilot like yeah these
these are not it's always like tom de
long or like some
crazy [ __ ] way you know joe rogan
would talk to you on his old sci-fi show
like i'm not listening to a goddamn word
that guy but then when you get like real
like
naval like captains right yeah and this
guy isn't lfo just means
an unidentified object right right my
dad worked at uh worked at norad and
worked at the pentagon uh
in the 70s it was high level um air
force intelligence
and he's like unexplained
uh objects in our airspace is absolutely
not
strange it happens quite often actually
but
not having some level of reasonable
explanation as to what it might have
been um
that is new and this this this doesn't
make much sense no because you have you
have these engineers talking about the
way it was moving at the speed and the
temperature they can't explain it yeah
they don't know what's going on we have
real experts analyzing it
because and also there's no propos like
there's no fire there's no
push they don't know because usually
there's an engine they can't figure it
out
it's real fascinating it is fascinating
go to current events
current events with the guys it's
current events with the guys
and cat and cat current events with the
guys
okay so on monday
dave chappelle went and visited kanye
west after his meltdown because
a couple of hours after that whole
presidential rally situation happened
kanye jumped onto twitter and had
a twitter storm where he was saying that
kim and kris jenner are trying to get
him locked up into some sort of mental
asylum he's been trying to divorce kim
for years
get out was based off of his life uh
just a lot of really weird incoherent
things
and so he quickly deleted all those
tweets or whoever's running his page
deleted those tweets
dave chappelle went to go check up on
him and this
is the video this one here
yep please just make us mad the world
needs some
you know we need some some joy yeah we
need a smile
brotherhood is real love is real
it's awkward they made this video he
made him make this video
if you keep watching it it feels very
awkward because kanye keeps trying to
get dave to say a joke
there's no need for this like why do you
have to blast the world that dave spell
came
to check on your well-being and uh let
me ask you guys nothing a comedian likes
more than when you're on your personal
time and they say make us laugh please
just i'm just shooting
presbyter just so give us a little
insight what the the fans are gonna see
tonight
what the [ __ ] uh no awkward oh my god
you imagine like this is awkward james
cameron was on an interview and they're
like
tell us a little bit about uh some
scenes in the movie before we go see it
tonight at the movie rear can we just
can you get some it's so strange this
the whole thing
it's sad man it's very sad it is and uh
i'm
glad you said that i listen kanye much
like president trump
he makes a lot of this himself because
he has been such a polarizing figure
but we're we're watch i'm not a
professional
but i really feel like we're watching
mental illness at play here
and it's not it's not entertainment it's
not funny we shouldn't all be gathering
around going oh
this is what's next this is a sick man
and he needs he's the father of four
yeah that's the bigger problem he's
father four what did she have how many
kids she actually had she carried one to
term
or how many kids i think she had two to
term herself and then two through her
surrogate yep
i i don't know i feel i do i genuinely
feel bad for the guy and i don't i just
don't think this type of attention is
is helping if probably hurting so much
more and i promise you dave shrill
didn't come out there so you put it on
twitter and you came to
check on your well-being even dave's
probably this is the [ __ ] problem
dude
yeah twitter and instagram doesn't need
to know your entire personal life
stevo um always tells them and i would
never talk about someone else's
kind of recovery but he's obviously a
public figure and has talked about this
himself so many times
i think it's a really important story
he's like um you know stevo made a
living
for doing stunts in front of a camera
and he's been open
i desperately need attention and i want
attention from
posting these things and doing these
stunts and when he got
really close to the end um you know the
jackass guys did a real intervention
and when they all showed up uh steve was
like yeah dude
he got out the cameras and uh he said it
was
right then when i knew because johnny
knoxville i don't know if you ever met
the guy
there's only varying levels of happy
there's no
there's no upset johnny knoxville really
he's just
varying degrees of super goofy and happy
but he said and knoxville had this
mean angry look on his face and just
smacked the [ __ ] out of the camera out
of his hand
and he's like this isn't we're not here
for a [ __ ] skit
this isn't a joke and like i i just
don't feel like
anyone's in a position with kanye where
they do that because
it's really strange in one way you're
dealing with mental illness and it seems
to me
a colossal narcissist correct so yeah
if i could run for president yeah i mean
the whole thing is this is not
it's it's it's troubling too because i i
love
the fact that we still out of all the
countries in the world
i'm not the guy who's going to see him
be like america number one did not even
open the debate but i do believe
that we are it's a great argument that
we still are the greatest country in the
world because we
really do have personal freedom even
places like canada
germany england you can get you can get
action you know law enforcement can say
something or do something for things
that you say
and things that you do in your own
personal space and time
but with mental illness like this it's
it's
it's like a really tough one because you
can't you can't take an adult and just
say like this [ __ ] guy or gal is
crazy
they're gonna kill themselves they're
gonna hurt someone else unless they
prove that
yeah the medical community can't do
anything
with kim kardashian say what you want
about it oh she's married to that
you got to deal with that [ __ ] all the
time that's the father you're kidding me
you never know what's going to happen
no think about that the kids are like
and i and i don't look i'm not
i think it's it's silly that they're so
rich and so famous
but it seems i don't think like the
kardashians are bad people
i know that and i think that a lot of
the the way the reason why people are
sitting back going like oh [ __ ]
kanye's crazy like
they don't acknowledge the suffering
that might be going on here because it's
the kardashians and it's like no
they're human beings they're not they're
not okay they're just there's reality so
it's a billion dollars you'd rather have
just a hundred dollars be mentally i
don't care what your view is or how big
your house
is if you have to live inside your own
head that's no [ __ ] joke man
i got to know chloe and chris a little
bit
how so um i uh was
they were screen testing me to host the
x factor remember when they brought the
x factor to america
yeah um
they were i was like really really in
the running to host that show
who ended up posting it uh mario and
mario lopez and mother and chloe
he's a much better version of me
but he but he's also not threatening i i
i
[ __ ] that one up on my own because so
did you start yelling at chloe no i went
to a meet at the final meeting at uh
simon cowell's house
in up in the hills of beverly hills nice
house
it's exactly like a bond villain's house
like it's
i've been to some nice places this was
number one this was
like are you [ __ ] this is a joke
right i'm on punk he created american
idol yeah
it's all it's very non-descript from the
outside it looks it looks like the
studio it's just like bricks and
like like concrete and [ __ ] you're like
well what the [ __ ] am i at the right
place
all of a sudden i go up to the intercom
and i'm like uh my name's mike i'm here
to see
i think and this [ __ ] wall goes this
is it opens up
and there's dudes buffing his bugatti i
swear i know this sounds like
i swear to god there's like a couple
dudes washing
his bugatti and there's another like
sick car in the in the in the
garage and i'm like oh okay so we walk
in
the whole living room is an infinity
pool inside
and there's just like bridges and one
center island of land where he's
on the couch sitting there chain smoking
this [ __ ] insane tv he's like dr evil
yeah and the the ins the the indoor
infinity pool goes outside
underneath like florida seating glass
and just drops off the hills into
hollywood obviously doesn't have
toddlers
not back then i think he does have a kid
now but this was 10 years ago
so we're sitting down we're having and
then he starts showing me some clips
of the british version we're just
discussing it and he was
very nice and very cool and he's like
you know what i want here
something different than i do i want to
i want someone who's
who's edgy i want someone who's
unpredictable yeah i go to you
and i go no you don't thinking there was
gonna be like some
recognition and the room said he's like
he's like what do you mean i was like
well you don't really want that i mean
it sounds good but you don't really want
someone on live television that's
unpredictable and edgy you want probably
someone who's going to be reading the
teleprompter and
keep some and he's like ah
seems like you have it figured out
better than i do and i'm like uh no no
no no i don't i know
you see i didn't get the job
but i did do a bunch of screen tests
with chloe and so in between the filming
we would
spend you know we've spent three or four
hours at a time just sitting there
shooting the [ __ ] in the green room and
like she's a nice lady
really nice and and funny and
self-deprecating and you know
how was she with the teleprompter not
good yeah but then good but neither am i
and and it's not it's a real
it's a real like that's what have you
scout free teleprompter look are you
you got to get used to i've done it a
lot are you a harvard
law graduate if you can do that no but
it's a skill and like the seacrest and
the carson daly's
mario lopez and stuff a lot of people
who really do it well they can and make
it seem like they're not reading
something
it's a skill yeah but it's also doing it
a lot yeah it's just doing a lot
all right next one okay so walmart the
other day announced that
starting this thanksgiving it's going to
be the first time since the 1980s that
they have
officially closed why uh one they're
afraid of covey concerns
to they want to allow their workers who
have been working during this pandemic
to have some more family time
they're also going to be allocating i
think 428 million dollars to
pay the workers a bonus who have been
working during this pandemic that's good
that's what i'm talking about good all
right
next chronicles all right there you go
oh and on monday jeff
with walmart low energy huh no i
couldn't oh you know just just with
water
walmart takes my energy though oh my god
walmart takes my energy away
business what yep on monday jeff bezos
made
13 billion dollars
from just the stocks his stocks for some
reason on monday
just go i think it raised eight percent
jesus christ and yeah he made 13 billion
dollars in one day since the divorce in
his wife like the second she's just rich
i think she's the
richest woman but she's like she's on
the top ten i think most top ten of uh
most richest people i think
in general but for women she's number
one god that's the [ __ ]
is that cool i wish she was like two
pockets i mean just like throwing money
in place
buying buying male [ __ ] what else god
uh these are fan submissions i wish i
remember their names but so this is
one this is is that a gal it's a girl i
kept tagging you yes brian
she's fantastic this is for brian
i guess her name is julia foreign and
this is her what whoa instagram page
that's a little much for me i'm not
gonna lie i think you'd have fun with it
that's a little much for me but i
do appreciate her she's pretty that's
just a lot it's too much testosterone
face is pretty
well but when you take that much human
no she's growth hormone that's all that
that is women
commonly look like i mean that doesn't
mean that looks
well that looks a little bit like my
chest go to the one
go the one where she's in the mirror
she's got a great sh i mean
her dress she would have been very her
triceps are crazy man
some guys are into that you got her
shoulders are nuts yeah some guys who
are in the guys
she's she's uh you enjoy this it's just
too much this is finally too much yeah
it's too much
it's too it's too um well there's all
there's all uh
it's all hormones and testosterone and
out of control [ __ ] well
hey bubba those crossfit girls you like
same [ __ ] just less
i know that they do a lot of let me let
me go to the go to
the ass pic when do you get test [ __ ]
that's the that's
like that's my i draw the line of test
[ __ ] yeah
it looks like a little i saw i've
experienced that
experience very large clits yes i
experienced it with a bodybuilder who
was
an ex-bodybuilder and she said i don't
want to talk
wait i guess
it was from steroids she has a very she
had a very
huge [ __ ] and what would you do she said
just so you know and you know when i was
would you
give you a heads up when i was touching
it and i was like
that's the biggest did you did you
belated huh
you do i did i feel sick i don't want to
talk about it
okay this is a long time your old mouth
and those creatures for a long time i
was much younger i was in my
it's kind of like actually 20 years ago
i'm changing my mind i kind of like it
no now i wish she had left herself alone
because before she's pretty
she can tell her face she's pretty very
pretty before all this i mean some
people are into this
oh my gosh doesn't look kind of like a
no this is going to sound mean
but like if michelle waterson were to
get on crazy amounts of steroids
very beautiful i'm just saying no i'm
just saying like no she doesn't look
never mind
never mind never mind looks nothing like
17-inch arms holy mackerel yeah
all right next one jack city son
all right it was just too much it's just
simple to listen if you like
it but i appreciate you bringing it to
my attention fire away
i appreciate you bringing my attention
it's just too much another
fantastic army i think they tagged you
on this one too right now yeah
it's a four it's like a 4x4 porsche that
can go off-road
and on-road it's so [ __ ] they're so
they're going to work on this a specific
car
oh geez i want to buy now porsches
you know porsche ain't going to work on
this they only do racing
i wonder the concept of sick
i would love to watch daniel craig [ __ ]
people up in that like like swiss
mountain
no there's a guy who already does a
rogan hat on his podcast he's a huge car
guy and he has a carrera
that he basically put 4x4 wheels on it's
sick looking
a lot of them have four by four right a
lot of them have all the all-wheel drive
yeah there's all these
4s yeah yeah the 4s
uh you get the 4s turbo i think it's a
monster you seen the new bronco mike
yeah
my wife wants it they're sold out like
crazy right
yeah even though they're like doubling i
got a notice yesterday because there's
the
they're called the first edition and so
it gets it's every option the sasquatch
package the
35-inch tires everything it's the the
best one you can get
they they send out a thing goes you know
you got selected to be the
the one of 3 500 you get the first
edition congrats i'm like okay cool
two days later hey so the demand was so
high we're actually making it 7 500 so
if you don't want the
first edition you can pull out now
because they
they they told us 3 500 which makes it
super exclusive
and then they bumped it to 70 because of
such a demand and those next
35 100 sold out in like seconds
i'm okay with that i'm just happy to see
like an american truck getting that kind
of
dude america hasn't done something hyped
like this in a long time
that bronco is sick it's pretty awesome
what else you got
all right my buddy joe sent this in it's
a chronovirus
um recommendations by the seat the
canadian cdc right
use glory hole so this is actually on
their government website
right here that's [ __ ] use barriers
like walls eeg
glory holes that allow for sexual
contact but prevent close face-to-face
dumb [ __ ] it's actually on
their government website
although i think glory holes are
fantastic i was going to say i don't
know
i'm not mad at a glory you know you're
so mad no i've never been but why
are you mad at california
i've never done that i'd be i should do
that i'd be down yeah
i used to let's make one here use a hole
yeah i used to watch that show
uh gigolos and some girl hired all the
jiggles she must have been balling
then she had some dude built like a box
like a square box that she got into and
she had a bunch of holes in all six guys
put their dicks in the hole great
episode new season finale
what the [ __ ] was that that was just her
thing the guy who killed that woman was
in there so that was her thing she was
just into all the dicks
yeah she just showed pictures that might
have been you porn either way
i think it was on gigolo i think it was
i think it was you know that was gigolo
i probably could have been hannah
montana that's sorry i
am getting into a box with a bunch of
dicks i like to do it with like like
they're laughing those jigglers
one one chick and five guys and then you
they go and you it's almost like dick
glor like russian roulette that's what
they were doing
yeah the guys were laughing they were
laughing at each other yeah you can just
hope that you could be fun with your
buddies
i guess i don't know what else you got
stick your dick in there all right this
is the last one this is a
a mother trying to fetch her wallet from
a crocodile pit or gator pit
oh come on and her kids like at least
one of her sons followed her in
this is pretty crazy you got to be
careful now he's a little kid you'll see
him in the video [ __ ] dude
oh he's probably eight seven
you gotta keep little children away from
a [ __ ] gator dumbo
she drops her wallet in there and the
gators aren't huge or anything but
that's her
she's oh that one grabbed it yeah so
this girl right here that's the mother
that dropped her wallet and she's on the
phone
yeah and the kids there kids in there
what could possibly be in there that's
so important probably if it's a big
gator you're in trouble
so kids are walking around get that
[ __ ] kid out
oh my god very true compelling argument
[Music]
and they're definitely big enough to
tear you up you know that kid's
well they're they're ambush predators so
there's a bunch of them they're small
that's so disappointing they're babies
so her wallet's right there you can see
the pink
so she's she's tossing rocks and small
she's tossing rocks in to like you know
get there for that kid man look at that
one creeping up dude
they think she's gonna feed him that's
also how they feed him yeah i don't know
why don't they just throw like a chicken
breast way far away and then that's a
good point
there were like no other officials there
either no park officials she grabs it
oh she needed her wallet well where's
the kid at man how much cash would have
to be in your wallet for you to do that
i mean if they're big and if they're
crocodiles there's no money but
alligators that big probably not i'm not
doing any of it [ __ ] my wallet dude
i just can't think of anything unless
it's cash that why wouldn't you just
if it's a castle rewrite the check
if it's saltwater crocodiles obviously
get them now i'm not doing any of it
especially my [ __ ] kid
yeah but for her to have her kid in
there that's the biggest problem so
they're trying to press charges they're
trying to find out who she is
well she's a [ __ ] yeah yeah so that was
just a [ __ ]
brainerd minnesota what could you do
little [ __ ] yeah soda huh
yeah minnesota
mikey likes you guys mikey likes you the
greatest health and fitness podcast
maybe oh no mikey likes for sure i
thought you're saying mikey likes you
mikey likes you
okay watch this show mikey like shin's
feeling 100
you're negative thank god chain got his
negative test back
chin every pickle rick pickle rick
is that it mike we love you this is the
final kid we're out
boom